can you manage can you cope with what's
coming your way this than 500 leaves one
made our population we do have less than
60 respirators just start you know what
not to kill many people we're gonna end
up going to kill many people
if the home battle with your many like
its
[Music]
if you were to ask an expert to pick a
continent where the coronavirus could do
the most damage he or she would probably
say Africa there were no ventilators no
I see you stuff more I see you mrs.
Norton ass titties but here's the thing
the continent seems relatively
unaffected by the virus so far and they
are all going to a farm out there and
that mom is getting thirds here they
don't have money for so but you know
it's true up against all you know you
should house we've spoken to medics
around the continent who say the
countries where they live and work are
not prepared there are tens of millions
here living in communities that lack
basic facilities like clean water
how many ICU beds do you have access to
and as for those specialists intensive
care beds and equipment like ventilator
see
well there aren't very many to go around
they do motive even our ICU facilities
to do with just one patient we add
stories of Internet has been prodded
from private practice no plugs into
isolation centers it that's why there
are people here who think Africa will be
overwhelmed by the virus Koba 19 has
been detected all over Africa but the
numbers of those infected just haven't
skyrocketed like they have in Europe and
the United States of the 15,000
coronavirus patients have now died in
hospitals across the UK in Spain a total
of confirmed cases there now stands at
18,000 and 56 take this country South
Africa for example they've only recorded
a couple of thousand infections despite
the fact so many people live so close
together were a one-room house there is
about six people or so so it's still the
same you can exceed people stuck in one
room for the whole team if I'm infected
maybe this man is not infected I'm
spreading the virus today people
scientists aren't really sure why the
numbers are so low but they do have a
couple of theories I want to take a
moment to highlight Africa first we may
not know how bad the situation is here
because African countries haven't done
that much
testing the w-h-o is saying test test
test
can you get a coke in nineteen testing
the community where you're based I was
one it's the capital which is about 1214
hours drive away in Nigeria with a
population of 190 million they've only
managed to test a tiny proportion of
people then there's the fact that
Africans are generally younger the
average age here is 19 and kovat 19
tends to disproportionately affect the
old and thirdly there are some people
who think that mandatory injection
programs for things like tuberculosis
may be slowing the virus's advance well
general boost of the immune response
they can protect also against other
types of infections over the past
century the BCG vaccine has protected
tens of millions from tuberculosis and
some scientists think it can be
repurposed to help control kovat 19 it
could be a very important tool to bridge
this dangerous period until we have on
the market a proper specific vaccine
against corona virus
Cygnus is a serious disease people are
dying so we are taking it serious some
countries in Africa have been in
lockdown for weeks despite the low
number of cases but that brings its own
challenges the security services stand
accused of violently and
indiscriminately enforcing these
shutdowns for money and Bailey says he
was whipped by officers in his own
garden thousand bombers are vulnerable
in jail ng in Isaiah and I was no
Monsanto corn in bump it is art Integra
and guys go 10 gr and equal rights and
hunger is driving people out of their
homes
dozens of shops and supermarkets have
been broken into over the last week
imagine there are many more to Syria
finding answers then how you expect them
to be there it's not a question of if
the infection rates across Africa rise
it's a question of when
you know people here they just can't
self isolate you're not going to stay
inside if you share a shack with six
other people not easy not easy and
you're not gonna stay home if you don't
have anything to eat
they need to at least go out get water
and so you know it's kind of like what
you ought to be infected or stopped
that's why the experts are so worried
the people of Africa are vulnerable to
the corona virus and their governments
lack the ability I'm afraid to treat
them when they're sick